good morning Millennials welcome back to
the most prestigious the most
groundbreaking the most real the
Millennial morning show the morning
toasts the most real I'm just trying out
some new like slogans for us right now
because the ones that we have are great
but I guess that we could evolve never a
morning show is good and that's really
just like a perfect way to explain to
someone what it is the Millennial
morning show the social media morning
show yes the most prestigious morning
show her social media the the Peabody
award-winning morning show yes Elon
Musk's favorite morning show I'm wearing
a lipstick that I have like I haven't
not worn the same color or like at least
the same shade for like over a year and
I'm like looking and it looks like I had
like a lollipop in my mouth
it's so pink does look really different
it is very pink do you like it I yeah oh
it's my lipstick so yes of course I
think you like it on me specifically not
generally cuz like I can go over there
and wipe it off you know don't wipe it
off it looks good for today but I don't
know if it's your morning color but see
it's really like maybe more for an
evening for you Oh evening we know where
to the TPG Awards oh yeah and I just
feel like I ate the Jolly Rancher and
it's like Here I am
I didn't have a jolly rancher which is
so so might as well have had had one
good morning Millennials I feel like we
were just here yesterday but so much has
happened since I sat in this chair
yesterday right 225 hours ago 25 hours
ago here's what happened in those 25
hours I got a home a home was made Tom
Selleck put his foot on my merch why his
foot cuz he stepped on it and he didn't
know what it was it was a blueblood
thing no he literally let your foot in
it it's not the proud family says put
your partner the proud family know when
like her grandma has her secret recipe
and they like I forgot what she's making
and they take it to the the bake-off or
whatever they bake obviously they have
to ask what's in your recipe and she
goes why I put my foot in it and they
were like haha sob and she was like no
my foot in it never was so crust eating
it it's an iconic proud family
never literally anything from proud
family except proud family their push
buttons make you wanna hug them
something about create a litte bit that
was a litte deep song it was a lifting
song I thought it was like a
disappointing show I forgot who the lead
was but I loved her and I just thought
she could just ship so much spunk she
she really didn't I just thought she
could do better show wise know I had its
moments it's rated high and it was also
animated which is just really tough when
you're going up against that I've action
shows when you're yeah like when you're
going again it's not only live-action
like the golden era of live-action like
even Stephens Hannah Montana that's or
even Cory in the house like and you're
animated and you're animated and like
not even well like you're animated very
poorly like the interns that Pixar
animated yeah you know someone just
comes it honestly jacking your mind is a
steel trap chewy it's so crazy I
remember like just everything it's like
annoying cuz like it's one of us has to
know but it's like even if I had like a
normal average memory you just
remembering stuff is like annoying like
if I there's something I want like
history to forget like you're gonna
remember it you're gonna be like and
they're gonna hire you mcgraw-hill is
gonna hire you to write our textbooks
it's like you guys think I have a great
memory like that and that I'm a steel
trap a library a wealth of knowledge but
Dana is so much more she tells me
stories or things that I said are things
that I did and like Wow who's she she
sounds great it's why I inflicted you
are to me as I am to Dana like she's
always telling you new things about
myself it's why are they interesting to
hear stories and things that you did
that you don't recall and you're just
like marveling at what an interesting
person you are right how going right how
funny how witty so Jackie and I were
telling you guys a little while ago one
of the the questions to get into our
Facebook group is are you a Claudia or a
Jackie and explain why and people it's
like really a grandiose versions of
ourselves and someone wrote something
today that was like highly hurtful and I
still let her in cuz like it wasn't
wrong you know she's like I'm much more
of a Claudia you know cuz I never brush
my hair is that my thing like do I the
unkept hair no that's like I feel like
you always have your hair kempt as like
the bare minimum you know also you have
naturally nice hair you don't really
have to do anything wait well now I'm
like so self-conscious because if my
hair wasn't done every day I would truly
look like I just rolled out of bed but
you like I don't have naturally on the
breath you could have made that argument
because I might I'm hop I used to like I
now go back and I'm like damn I can't
believe I showed up on a morning show
looking like the way that I did no but I
remember there was one day you showed up
to the breath where you realize that if
you parted your hair oh yeah Charice
part and just brush it and didn't go to
sleep with it wet that it would look
really nice and from that day forward
you've always had kempt hair so yes
maybe she's talking about Mac maybe but
I don't know I just feel like whether
when I learned that for like I have
naturally good hair so in high school I
like never did it but sometimes or it's
messier than others and running a comb
just to your part in making your part
stick straight and then like flattening
the top literally it's like blow up a
world of difference a world of
difference even though I'm getting a
haircut next week because the Revlon
blow-dryer I've been like coming out of
control my hair starting to break and
like I've always pride myself on having
healthy hair so I'm trying to cut back
and I need to cut it in order for it to
grow and be back to the place that it
was ad I'm gonna also need a haircut
before Olivia's wedding I need a haircut
- is it an appointment I can piggyback
on both so Margot's already piggybacking
on it cuz it's at Michelle's but she
said she had between 1:00 and 4:00
Margot took 2:30 I took 3:30 you can
take one-third okay I just need a little
trim
tonight hairs growing everyone think my
hair's going so fast what am i doing
like I'm on steroids um but I've been
growing it for over a year like I feel
like this is a normal piece but do you
ride bro I do not worried I think the
key to hair growth is patience and
you've got to grow through the awkward
times you know what they say about
patience it's virtue it truly is and
then I'm just gonna bring working today
let it grow I am one with the wind and
sky let it grow that's a good one look
you tell you looks very normal I feel
like I look normal thank you think
you're going to class on a fall winters
Eve you know and I feel like I look a
little Christmassy
you look very ho much cuz it's like this
shirt from certain angles that could
look black but it's really like in the
show it's looking emerald it's look it
is emerald it's really a Christmas tree
green it is xle by Lauren Elizabeth and
I just feel like I'm always saying I'm
wearing XL you by Lauren Elizabeth like
she sends me stuff and I wear it to the
bone it's interesting no it's my fault I
didn't fill out the sizing info I just
like wasn't comfortable
that around but now that I'm like a
skinny size eight sometimes I have to
send it around I have you changed my
sizing info because when she sent it I
was like feeling medium yeah but this I
could have used a small but it's no I've
never felt medium and I love this shirt
it's so professional game and it looks
very comfortable it's great job Lauren
Elizabeth the people on the podcast must
be so thrilled check out my Instagram at
Jackie O problems I'm public right now
but you just never know how long that's
gonna be forced you should follow me I
like your earrings thank you I got them
for my birthday I know I just left
noticed them because your hair's behind
your ears that's what I like about these
earrings it's like they're not in your
face but it's like a nice touch
also we got a lot of comments yesterday
and I was gonna ask you in person but I
was just like in my own head with the
bluebloods thing what did you do to your
eyebrows different okay I'll tell
everyone because I you know it's been a
long path for me to accept the fact that
I should color my eyebrows I feel like
you would go to slam poetry and like
write a poem no totally or like if I was
applying to college now I would write my
essay about my eyebrows instead of my
hair cuz I come to terms with my hair
like ten times over to come to terms no
but like growing up as like well first
I'll just being in a team you know you
have to learn to love yourself but be
having red hair is very difficult and if
you don't have it you wouldn't have well
know it's like this is gonna be very
controversial we're about to say but
it's like if you're born a redhead and
you're a girl you are either like so
special and gorgeous looking or like no
offense you like our circus freak so
thank God no you are on the right side
of history no it's just and if you don't
know how to cuz sometimes when I wake up
in the morning like bare face like I'm a
little scary-looking not gonna like I'm
not gonna lie and you don't have to lie
either but it's you have to like know
what to do and your color it takes a
long time right and if all your friends
are brunette like how are you gonna
learn how to be a redhead that is so
true and our parents are in redheads
like where we supposed to learn I don't
know it's so great and we grew up before
the age of YouTube right it wasn't like
a Madeline patch to learn from know so
interesting it was took a long time of
learning and understand like
appreciating my hair and now it's just
like I can't imagine not having red hair
totally and now it's so my eyebrows are
the next hurdle and in the past three
years I've made great strides like what
I've been doing up until this point I
think is very fair and I think it
pleased the Instagram community and I
still felt like myself and I forget why
I even took it one step further I think
I was starting to look and like in
person I always look like I've eyebrows
but in pictures I
we don't and so I was like you know what
maybe I'll kick it up a notch and for
Halloween when we were being Kourtney
and Kim I went to Sephora and I bought
the product that I used but in the
darkest need to be Kourtney because I
really wanted her eyebrows but it wasn't
even dark enough I had to put mascara on
my eyebrows so then I had this really
dark brown color and on Thanksgiving in
Utah I was just experimenting with it
because I just wanted like a little bit
darker and I and I kind of liked it
okay I'm saying I'm so loving it like
and you know you're getting better today
is better than yesterday tomorrow will
be better than what I have to do so I've
been mixing benefit gimme brow in the
shade one which I normally used and 4.5
I just need to get shade number two or
three so and it'll be a little bit more
yeah I usually like a literally shade
5ug shade 5 yeah I like having dark
eyebrows yeah I want like Liz Gillies
eyebrows you're still look super dark
well because I lost my eyebrow gel and
Utah addresses how you lost your
eyebrows oh well I lost some of those
too but I lost my gel so I've been like
you know keeping it low-key these days
no it looks nice that's why the lipstick
really is stark today because you don't
have a lot of other makeup on it's just
like it looks wrong I can't look at the
feet anymore because like I just truly
look like I'm drinking a lollipop know
what brings out the pink and you're in
your spider you look great thank you
yourself okay I want to talk about two
things that blue eyes I have to talk
about blue bloods because how many
toasters watch like am I on the outs
well so are you know so there's like a
general understanding amongst I think
like the network and everyone like it is
like an older person's show because it's
been around for a while Tom Selleck was
like the when the show was first
promoted it was promoted as like Tom
Selleck's on TV and the people who know
Tom Selleck are from Hawaii five-o or
whatever magnum p.i magnum p.i okay and
it's like Tom so it's an old and friends
too so like alright and now I think like
it's really because it's in its eighth
season and it's so good it's really
transitioning into like I don't want to
say but like the new SVU I was gonna say
it gives me sort of Lauren Turner vibes
like it's much better nobody dislikes
Law & Order but not everybody watches it
all right and I would now argue that
it's better than Law & Order because law
and order
only after what's-his-face left Stabler
did they start to develop the characters
like personalized and she has a kid in
like any episodes feel it yeah they
weren't like one-off yeah it was like
you had to like it wouldn't became a
used to be I could watch the show any
episode of SVU and you wouldn't need to
know what happened before that or after
word for that type of show linear linear
is it's like when they're all connected
okay I'm making this up by the way and
then when they're like random episodes
like Disney Channel shows it's really
what they're called we're black mara
even when they're not connected right
you don't have to have seen them all to
watch one so SVU I think started to pick
up for like people missing Stabler and
like just what's the word I'm looking
for
um like makeup for something it's like
you know overcompensate or genius
overcompensate for like the lack of
Stabler and like they developed personal
life some relationships and kids are
like it's like it's not that interesting
whereas from the get-go Blue Bloods has
made it to know that it's a cop show
it's a family show but it's also
personal like the kid they got married
they're engaged kids she died like all
this stuff no no I didn't say him so it
established itself early on it's like
both a personal and a cop show and it
really talks about real time issues like
in the latest episode it was all about
marijuana legalization and the police
commissioner is like I'm not gonna not
arrest people who have marijuana because
it's he's a big believer in the broken
window theory it's a can you start with
one thing people gonna be urinating in
the streets and but his daughter is
assistant district attorney who made
that law so it's very complicated and
now I think due to the toast and also
just like the show being really good and
like people on the show becoming famous
like Vanessa ray like she's like a young
cool girl she has 700,000 Instagram
followers now like we're bringing the
show to the 21st century
yes she's like so cute yeah and she said
she would come on the shows like she was
like when Margot was like you guys to
have her on the trust I'm like would you
she was like would I yeah she's amazing
she followed me and that was she she's
calling me she's got me guys but so let
me tell you about the set
it was so premium like first of all it
was in Greenpoint and it's like this ten
block radius just like full of studios
oh by the way I shouldn't say where it
is people go no nothing on the doors
sorry it was so premium I walk in and
like you think they're filming in a
house they're filming in an office
they're like in a building it's all a
set and like I knew that about TV but
like a part of me thought about housing
that's right it was Syria Lane
so it's like the dynasty house it
doesn't exist it doesn't know it's a set
like it makes me so sad
so yeah the house doesn't exist they
have like a picture of the house and
then they have the dining room that
hurts yeah so we got there just be
easier to get a house duh like and buy
it it's like an
most modest house in Queens it can't be
more than a million dollars right and
then he then you're in the full house
but the thing is is like there's not
enough space because they have the
dining room and then they have to have
all the space to get every camera yeah
so in a real house that wouldn't work
but I was just like learning so much
about film and everyone was so nice they
had put like a PA on us and like me and
my girl couldn't be controlled we like
we're walking upright are you guys
having earphones in okay so basically
they film in this dining room which is
like a built thing it has like four fake
walls and the only people who are in
there who Pete are people who need to be
in there like the actual cast and the
cameraman so then everyone else stands
right outside and watches haven't screen
watches on the screens but I don't know
why they don't have this oh because if
the screens are playing loud volume
you'll hear it right show so they gave
ever on these little headsets and me and
Margaret sitting libery behind the
director of the showrunner and we were
just like putting in our little
headphones and just like living it was
so crazy that we were there for two
hours they shot the same 30 second scene
7,000 times because there's so many
people in the cast because it's family
dinner so it's like eight people today
you have four cameras that need to film
every person at least four times and
then every person from a different angle
at least four times I could tell you the
whole scene but everyone oh but nobody
here that's New Year's resolution but
everyone was holding their own oh yeah
yeah except Gramps like couldn't
remember this line and like I was
laughing so hard and like you could hear
my laugh and they were like please quiet
down I was like I'm sorry I'm sorry but
Gramps like couldn't remember the sign
he was like that's the thing about that
we are you spoiling like it wasn't a
spoiler he makes you sign something or
say that they didn't and like I was
recording a bunch cuz we did it behind
the scenes for the patreon which that'll
be out today and no one like told me
anything it's not really a show that you
can spoil almost but then I have to tell
you what happened afterward so maybe
I'll find a way of course me and Margo
just sat there like minding our own
business everyone was so nice the show
like I was really acting like I was on
an audition like you never know like
never know you never know so I was
sitting to the show run and it's like
what if say they were filming an episode
in like the dead body dropped out so I'm
saying they just needed a body jacket I
was saying but you never know if they
need an extra the thing is about family
dinner it's like only the eight of them
but you never know you never know you
could have hired staff maybe someone
rings the doorbell could have been
catered getting shot yeah exactly so me
Margo were just like minding our own
business but like you know bopping
around and to craft services but the
bathroom like the PA who was supposed to
be a scientist like literally like
couldn't handle us
sort of sitting we're recording and then
they kept the great amazing what did
they have everything is it healthy and
in the video anyone yes if they change
from breakfast to lunch to dinner cuz
they're there for 12 hours so we were
there during like lunch snack time so
they'd healthy snacks that snacks
healthy meal that meal like and because
there's over 300 people work on the show
so it's just like so premium like that
was my favorite I had a pop-tart yum i
napped Osen no no no I didn't want to
take up too much time enough toast
exactly so me and Margaret mudding our
own business and it's so funny because
when this one the scene when the cut is
over they have to relight they the food
moves so they have people come sit in
for the cast and it's like fake versions
of Tom Selleck Tom Selleck so who's this
guy who wore glasses and has a mustache
and is the same height as Tom Selleck
they just need him just sit for lighting
right but he they all like take their
role seriously and they literally become
looking like the people that's so funny
it was hysterical Tom Selleck walks out
basically all the cast hangs out in this
other room while they're restaging Tom
Selleck comes out over to us so nice
shook my hand he he he came to me yes
and we were just like hi he was so nice
so gracious he had printed our Oh in
love with him in love he had printed out
articles like about he has a tattoos he
had printed out articles like about news
and was like handing it to the writers
you think this would be interesting like
he's involved in the creative it was
very impressive and he came out twice
two times this happened he was just like
asking me questions I had a blue bloods
hat like nobody could believe like where
I got it and I was like I don't know
literally someone sent it to me in the
man whatever then the scene finally
wrapped and they moved on to something
else so like we weren't really invited
to I mean we're like gathering our
things and Donnie Wahlberg comes over
and he falls me on Instagram but he
doesn't like know my face and I he
didn't didn't know who I was he was just
so lovely and gracious he was like hi
how are you shook my hand oh you like
the show that's so great I'm so happy to
hear that what do you do and I'm like
I'm girl in a job he was like yeah girl
with no job Chuck is he got his cell
phone taking 1 million photos of me
FaceTime Jenny oh my gosh she was in the
lobby of Sirius XM I was I
I knew who's been on her show I've been
on her show I don't think she remembered
you he was just like so he respected the
hell out of Carla Jean job like he
couldn't believe it he was at pictures
pictures pictures want a picture with
Mark I want a picture with me then
Vanessa ray and her on-screen fiance
Jamie came over and he came over and he
was like dirty jeans and I was like I
gave him merch I brought March I would
brought him dirty sheets March he's like
five days in a row he was so hot and
like so nice and she was just like an
angel from God like I just first saw
she's so pretty like she'd been sitting
all day like doing the same [ __ ] line
and they have to actually eat when
they're on dinner so she was English
turned me in smart and she was just
because she had to eat a million times I
want to get nauseous if something worse
be for something so I was just like so
bewildered by the grace and elegance and
just the kindness of everyone to set
there really are friends because when
the take was over they were like we said
they were still sitting there like you
could hear their conversations they were
talking about this went on a date like
this another girl they were making such
funny jokes so someone was like to Jamie
and when in the line was like you should
I hope you grow up to be like him and
when the scene was over Diane Wahlberg
was like he's 40 he's already it was so
funny there was just like such a great
dynamic between the cast
there's no fuse I was like everyone I
was like literally being a reporter like
[ __ ] what was her name Harriet the
Spy I was like so who has view you know
anyway not get along and they were like
no yeah and I think that's like the
general goal of everyone who works there
is like this is like an SVU Ted chaough
and they're in season 8 and I think the
ratings are great and I was like I was
telling everyone I'm like I needed to
know who makes the most money like I was
being so annoying Tom Selleck obviously
makes much money per episode and
somewhere on Google Margo said she had
250,000 I heard 800,000 but CBS paid
those kids with that terrible show Big
Bang Theory a million dollars an episode
so like they have the budget so I think
it goes like this
Donnie Wahlberg oh no sorry Tom Selleck
Donnie Wahlberg I don't know the cast is
like literally 30 people and I was just
like Vanessa I'm like Harriet you did
not do no I did I was making everyone
uncomfortable I was like then I said you
know what Jamie makes whatever his real
name is will she's like no I would never
ask I'm like well do you know what
Jimenez makes he's like no I've never
asked him I got I mean I'm like well
Google says this imagine if you
into a workplace and just started asking
people if they knew what their
co-workers make fifty-fifty but actually
I've heard when I was like back in the
corporate world that it's actually
really good to have salary transparency
because then you know where you stand
right and if you're like being taken
advantage of or not only that if you
think you're the star of the show and
you're getting pay the lease like sit
down right now but if you're like doing
the same job as someone else in there
making more like you should know that
yeah everyone should actually tell their
salaries cuz it's like also if you like
if if you and I worked in a corporate
setting and I came over to Dean was like
hey what's your salary like you get
fired for that
yeah then told me that because you
almost happen to I'm so glad that's how
much fun you really are almost pushing
me to start the show I just need the
jacket I honestly like it's really it's
an amazing show and all the way to start
it and like fall in love no it sounds
great like I would like it but if I
started my fell in love with it like I
will kick myself for not going with you
we're going back women that okay well
because here's the thing the reason I
got invited is because Ali is a girl who
follows me and she's a writer for the
show but she only gets to like direct
the show when it's an episode that she
wrote so yesterday I happened to have
been in episode that she heard she's
written like four or five she said so we
just would have to wait for the next
time they use one of her episodes well
that's gonna take me that long to it's
so good eight seasons and like I just
okay watch it and then before you watch
season seven finale just like prepare
yourself okay I already know what
happens because you already talked about
it and I'm pretty sure you reenact it on
your story oh I did um it's been the
five million on you but it's okay it
doesn't seem like it's a suspenseful
show if I can enjoy about every moment
show it's and you know what it is every
episode they debate some like a moral
issue and you really like it stumps me
sometimes I'm like well you know if you
did commit a crime for the sake of
sanity saving someone else like did you
really commit a crime you know it puts
like this perplexes in a very like Torah
that's what it is
those are the questions asked in the
Torah um okay sorry tangent for people
who don't watch Blue Bloods but like
please get into a click I don't want to
let's and I found that enjoyable so yeah
and I just learned so much like the
director turnaround is like do you know
why we do this thing and I'm like no bi
and he was teaching me Wow so are you
gonna get into film it looked like a lot
of work and it looked like you really
have to start from the bottom
except Donnie Wahlberg he was like oh my
god ready for actually that seems like
by the way are you doing apart is that
what you're here I'm like oh no
me Donnie and he was like why not they
should write you in I'll tell the
writers I said okay Tony do what you got
to do what you should be like Tom I say
it'll be a typical legitimate long-lost
daughter it was something it's not that
kind of show like Tom doesn't step out
he doesn't he doesn't please
it's better I said I'll be a dead body
but Vanessa said it's the hardest thing
to do because you can't breathe oh my
god look it's oh this is like actually
think I got any good because I'm really
good at holding my breath maybe close
your mouth cuz that'll make breathing
okay your neck is moving it is yeah cuz
you're like breathing okay this is
really fun for podcasts okay let's see I
think I think it'd be good and feel good
and your skin when you don't wear makeup
is like fleshy and you could look dead
thank you that's what I was trying to
say earlier okay good but your eyelids
are fluttering and also who dies with
their legs crossed and their arms lady
yeah do it again you're just gonna have
to figure out why your eyelids flutter I
don't know do your eyelids flutter when
you sleep I don't know okay never mind
you literally look like you're on heroin
like oh I can maybe be someone having a
seizure or you could die with your eyes
open that does happen sometimes Oh God
actually that looks pretty good it looks
good okay work on it also I did want to
tell you that I finally moved into my
apartment yesterday I heard you had
people over that why didn't your family
I had company yeah no my friends have
been dying to come over and my friend
Ana's bachelorette party is this weekend
and I can't go so like I felt really
guilty and she's been really wanting to
come over so I just gave in and I was
running around town like Bree van de
Kamp I got flowers I got food
I got rice I'd literally the handyman
whom I adore in my building like
literally came over and designed my
whole apartment moved all the furniture
hung all the art turned the table like
we just did everything and it really
look I got it really looks like a home
and nothing makes a home look more like
a home than flowers agreed I just kind
of get really nice bundles from plan
shed like that got them and it's just
classes up the gorge I love planchette
it's just so expensive I know even the
sale clearance I can't afford yeah but
like that will you pay for it but it's
still expensive but nothing really makes
your home feel more like adult than
flowers and candles
and I use those homesick candles that we
got from the last time we partnered with
hamsa candles and they smelled so good
and my I always forget to light candles
up until the second like the doorbell
rings so it's like you light it and then
you gotta wait an hour but they really
fragrance the place mad quick they
fragrance the placemat quick and they
have such a nice holiday winter candle
that's yeah see this is my favorite time
of year to light candles because you're
just like it's like a hug you know but I
need to get like my home into a a
seasonal like I want to be one of those
girls who has like white pumpkins you
know like I want and that thing on my
table like I was running those a runner
I want to be one of those girls like I
like to know it shop but to know it kind
of gal okay I think you could do it I'm
the first step the first step is candles
the candles are not only great for your
own home but great as gifts yes they
have seasonal flavors but they also have
candles by your seat so if you're
feeling a little homesick I mean we live
in our home state if we didn't I might
buy a New York candle just to smell you
know smell of trash yes I way anyways
right now our listeners who go to home
sick calming use promo code toast will
receive 10% off any order and fifty
dollars and get free shipping that's a
great deal 10% off any any order over
$50 and free shipping this amazing offer
and most popular state and city candles
won't last long so don't wait just visit
homesick calm now using promo code toast
to find a personal gift for your whole
list today including yourself get
yourself something nice treat joke so
I'm I want to get people holiday gifts
but I also want to get myself a holiday
gift I did I got myself a holiday if I
showed it to you oh you did I splurged
big-time and it's like annoying cuz it's
like a work-related thing no it's not
it'll change your life it will because
like so for my shows most of the time
it's I have one or two shows in a night
I flied the morning off after the choice
and I'm back the next day so it's really
like I don't need that much I need my
pajamas my costume my slippers my makeup
and something to sleep in
and the bag that I have is good like it
fits in most carry ons its fits a lot
but it's just so ugly like the suitcase
that I had and it's like now that I'm a
person of notoriety like you never know
when the Pats could show up you know and
I can't imagine me my paparazzi with my
big green suitcase Seifer I said the
Superbowl yeah bum TMZ told us they were
gonna
come find us at the airport and we liked
it our makeup in the bathroom and they
weren't there yeah right that's one
thing
so I splurged on a suitcase and I'll
show you guys on Instagram like I can't
believe I spend that much money on a
suitcase but whatever it's good because
I just got a new suitcase from away but
I didn't splurge it was like a normal
price and it's the four wheels I do not
like that I got it just in time for the
most hectic month of our lives traveling
miles wise I need four wheels because I
need to be able to just I have something
to say something controversial out the
four wheels they don't work like unless
you have the strongest wrist in America
to push the weight there oh it always
falls backwards no it works for me but
it only works on hardwood like not on
carpet so whatever anyway so I am all
for you treating yourself to a piece of
luggage especially because you're
traveling someone cuz I'm traveling so
much and I don't need it I could
expensed it right a suitcase I don't
know [ __ ] I should've asked your manager
okay okay half an hour later are you
ready for the past I'm literally half an
hour half an hour's of talking about
bluebloods later are you ready for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of the morning toast okay you ready by
the way out of the morning just you
always say that I don't know it's okay
weird this okay okay you are morning
toast I'm sorry take a bite out of I was
just my my heart wasn't bite out of your
morning George
yeah my heart wasn't in it because I was
just thinking about the reason why we
pushed off the stories for so long it's
cuz they all suck yeah and it's just
like the world did stop turning while we
were you know busy yesterday and for
that I'm grateful like in the past two
weeks there was a news every single day
and of course we're back it to work nada
nada the most interesting thing
happening on Twitter today is that there
is a man and actually are we doing that
story there is a man in Florida who is
they've come to their learn since 1970
he has killed over 90 women and he's
probably the deadliest u.s. serial
killer like in the past 50 years that's
crazy
and I think he's being put to death man
I got one thing to say about Florida
they sure not to kill people over there
and for that I'm grateful I'm gonna
caught up on the story we gotta like
kill Casey Anthony she's got a guy you
know actually I will no longer
contribute to the celebrity of serial
killers and that's why Casey Anthony
like does what she does she's empowered
by like Daily Mail right
her and I will no longer like talk about
her and make her famous so Casey Anthony
you've been China also we watched Black
Mirror on our trip and there was one
episode that we watched when you weren't
there and you should watch it I don't
want to say no but you should I'm
officially done with Black Mirror
because I don't like the way that it
makes me feel afterwards okay just watch
someone more no I like you guys tricked
me into watching white Christmas which
was the worst one of all in terms of
giving pits and I don't want to feel sad
anymore I don't want to question life
like literally when we watch that one
about the lesbians in heaven San
Junipero Wow oh he's so upset like she's
like littering on Tibet and I was like
literally had tears my eyes I was like
one day all the people I love are gonna
die like why do I want to know oh that
would only made me upset because
everyone said it's the best one and it
was by far the what we only watched five
and it was the worst out of them right
like that girl left her daughter and
husband in eternity alone right to run
off with another woman no but like even
I mean that I didn't whatever but just
the show itself and you guys didn't I
when we were watching it and it takes
you like 40 minutes and figure out what
you're watching that's the worst part I
was I kept saying I'm like she's a time
traveler like I thought you were being
crazy she doesn't know the dance she
doesn't know what to wear because she's
from a different time tote and I was
pretty much right and what like the
thing that was annoying about that is
that I think the premise of that actual
episode was good like that in the future
there is this like syndicated video game
where if you're unconscious or whatever
like you can't plan your afterlife like
that's cool but the way they did it
starting backwards was so confusing and
then the girl left her family I didn't
like it I didn't like it at all and I
really didn't like the one with the pig
and I'm done with that show I just I
watch TV to escape the treacheries of
the universe and I feel like black
mirror is literally honing in on the
treacheries of animals I'm good I'm
[ __ ] good thank you I'm good they
want you to look inward would you be
watching TV and miss the princess in the
streets of the prime-minister [ __ ] a
big stop no I would I can say with
certainty
I would not be watching but I probably
wouldn't be outside I'd just be watching
Riverdale
okay first story ariana grande's
dangerous woman tour is heading to
YouTube a behind-the-scenes look at
Ariana Grande's dangerous woman tour and
the making
her album sweetener is coming to YouTube
the forepart ariana grande dangerous
woman Diaries documentary series to be
released Thursday November 29th to day
oh ma lows the pop superstar during her
2017 tour and through the creation of
her third studio album sweetener that's
a long time
you to bills to docu-series as a love
letter to her fans YouTube does good
documentary he's like they did the Demi
Lovato one right simply complicated yeah
that was good this is a long period of
time through her dangerous woman tour
and then also writing sweetener right
does it capture anything Pete no solo
according to a YouTube rep dangerous
woman diaries will not address Grande's
short-lived engagement to SNL star Pete
Davidson which I don't like it's like if
you she had a crew filming her so just
address it yeah me said I feel
interesting look into just like
celebrity nowadays and I feel like
probably the impetus of of this
documentary it has a lot to do with
Manchester and maybe that would suppose
to be like the focal point like getting
through that but then so much happened
during the sweetener era just to forget
it and act like it didn't happen isn't
stupid yeah well so the dangerous woman
Diaries will include footage from her
one love Manchester concert last year
which was organized to benefit the
families of the suicide bomber attack
outside of the Manchester Arena so I'm
curious if they were filming but they
were just filming her tour right then
they have footage from Manchester I'm
sure it'll be really interesting
actually ya know so that is interesting
but that's gonna get lost
those people do film every concert
Taylor Swift dies but that's gonna get
lost because people now just want to see
life with Ariana and that can be like
this is actually the most interesting
like I think what's happened to her in
the past two years like on so many
different levels is she has like the
most interesting and like complex story
yeah and the fact that they've been
filming it I think will be just really
interesting and I feel like it's gonna
be a little black mirror ish like where
the consumers of her you know and this
the weight like the celebrity aspect of
it you know explain later understand
that's why I wish they would address the
P thing because her being engaged to P
for so short and releasing an album and
being at the height of her career and
her ex-boyfriend OD'ing and like the man
like I think she's just like peak
celebrity and I just think it's really
interesting
in time like the way that we have
consumed like her life yeah I also
really have like fallen in love with
celebrity documentaries recently because
the Lady Gaga one was just so fantastic
a green
I thought the temple Avada one was quite
telling I found out yesterday for my
friend olesya that there's an Ed Sheeran
one our YouTube I'm not in I don't know
if I'm interested yeah but I just I'm
excited for another celebrity
documentary is all I'm trying to say I
agree I love a good documentary mm-hmm
three identical strangers if you had a
hot-shit yet what are you still doing I
also will have a good documentary that
doesn't give you a pit look have you
ever seen the documentary I think the
best documentaries aren't meant to give
you pits have you ever seen the
documentary queen of Versailles yes of
course what the Cubs likes the best
documentary ever because who would have
thought when they started filming this
family because they're building the
largest house in America that's what the
dock in Florida in Florida modeled after
versus re and in the middle of
construction middle of construction in
the recession hit his like timeshare
business tanks and they went broke they
went broke like you have and it's just
crazy that they were filming it yep you
have to watch it yeah queen of
Versailles I wonder what they're up to
now that family sometimes they get
updated I think the daughter I think
their business bounced back something
sad happened to them recently I don't
want to speculate but I just remember
them being in the news but I believe
that their business bounced back I hope
so
[ __ ] I don't know if their house
didn't and when to the house likes sat
next to us movie of the week because I
was actually thinking we need to do one
cuz yes we doing dear toasters today
queen of Versailles toast movie of the
week we will talk about it next week
because now we're on a way more regular
schedule we're here all month except I'm
no I'm here for the rest of the week and
then I'm not here one day oh no I'm here
November was the craziest month for me
and thank you toasters for sticking with
it yes and just shucking and jiving
shucking and jiving actually maybe the
choice movie of the week this week
should be dangerous what makes I want to
watch it today I'm gonna watch it by the
way so you have to have YouTube red no
you could watch it on YouTube see your
shirt on your computer yeah okay I have
every YouTube connection you like so
YouTube TV you want to come over and
watch yeah cuz they probably have it
without commercials bring that to sneech
s okay but actually I was gonna ask you
if you wanted to go to blew me down
today because I need outfits for so many
things coming up I do and I need an
outfit I need a dress for our sister's
wedding meet you and now I am committed
to looking so if you blew me needles did
have quite a selection the last time I
went if you wanted to go
making it lunch - honestly the only way
I'd compensate for having to do
treacherous shopping is having lunch
first you know or actually after
especially at forty carats yeah that's
my favorite restaurant so now you guys
know where to find us today thank you
for that interesting piece of fact what
what is piece of fact piece of news back
to I fetch ID what's the next story Jack
next story is something I've been
putting off talking about for a while
because I thought it was really
speculation but then I read an article
and now I'm leaving it inside Megan
Markel and Kate Middleton's tense
relationship they were dubbed the new
Fab Four - this is like a whole in depth
thing my page six but I'm gonna just get
to the thesis the two dashing royal
princes and their dazzling wives but now
the cosy quartet of Prince Harry and
Megan Markell and Prince William and
Kate Middleton appears to be falling
apart at the seams
a growing friction between between the
two princes had has been matched by an
equally frosty relationship between
their wives and it is Megan Markel who
has found for herself meand as the
instigator of what royal insiders claim
is an extraordinarily tense time so at
first glance the decision of Prince
Harry and his wife to move to a new home
on the Queen's Windsor Park estate
seemed a natural step for the newlywed
couple a wage it wasn't a red flag
awaiting the birth of their first child
but by shunning moving into a Kensington
Palace apartment next door to Prince
William the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
have revealed serious cracks in the
group dynamic it was supposed to it was
suggested that Harry was annoyed that
his brother had not quote rolled out the
red carpet for Megan and made her feel
more welcomed in the firm only when
their father Prince Charles stepped in
was the spat resolved well that's that
anyway they have had quite a few
arguments one royal source claims this
is about Harry pulling away from his
brother okay so the rumours are that
Megan and Kate are not getting along
that Kate left
Megan's rehearsal dinner crying which is
weird and that the Queen had told Harry
before they got married to watch out for
Megan's behavior and her attitude so and
just what I've read like on many gossip
sites that are reputable and some that
are not is that Megan is having some
serious attitude problem like she is
just like diva extraordinaire which I
mean I would be too if I'm the princess
you know and when it comes to royal
family anytime you read something I just
automatically assume it's BS because how
does [ __ ] do you know like anyone they
are pride themselves on not doing a
motion not lipped not having drama like
at all
like the Queen's husband was cheating on
her and
she like didn't get divorced and she
didn't say anything and she just like
met him on a ship on the crown so I
don't I usually don't believe it but
they're people are not even talking
about it as a rumor it's just like that
like and the fact that they're moving
out into Windsor Castle it's not a good
look it's not a good look and I just
can't tell if it's like 100 percent true
or 100 percent speculation but a part of
me like the [ __ ] starter instigator and
me like wants to believe that it's true
and if I am believing that it's true I
have to just believe that it's not
Meghan's fault
B just because I've only heard bad
things about her right and like William
and Harry when we're not odds before
Mike know there was brushers but I'm the
one hand I guess my [ __ ] starter in like
this is salacious but on the other hand
like I'm more so like what a cute
[ __ ] family the Royals are and I
would rather see them together
Kardashians die or worse then like Rob
style right so wait that's the thing
it's like with family tips when you're
in the spotlight you can go to the Rob
way or it can go like we're sisters we
fight or we move on way and I really
hope it goes that way but it's so and
it's so early on yeah they don't owe
anything to each other they're not
related they're not connected by blood
and also it's so early on in their
relationship like literally year 1 of
marriage like this is not good no it's
not good and I don't know I just feel
like if I were a princess like I would
just be so happy to be there you know
who would I be fighting with oh my god
of course I'd just be so you know
grateful for the opportunity especially
being marrying into Princess Hood so you
had the choice because some princesses
are born that way and they don't look
and they don't want it right and they
never had a choice or they don't like
understand like how special it is
because they've never been anything
other than a princess right like if I
went from Deal or No Deal to Kensington
Palace I would be grateful yeah just
saying I could just imagine like Megan
Marco look I go back and forth between
like loving Megan Marco and like wanting
to protect her and then also like
knowing the real her and I feel like
she's one of those people who like gets
home takes off from a screams at the
staff you know well that's what they're
saying that she's mean she goes out in
the public and you think oh darling
hello darling it's love and love and
make wish we don't have we haven't had a
new wish our wish was Deb Cameron Ariana
Grande and a wicked spectacular okay
ready I got it Network show Network show
Network show Network show Network show
Network show Network show Network show
Network show Network show Network show
also I don't have an exact time or day
but Jackie and I are gonna be on the
leading podcast neck
we're filming it we're recording next
week they're like a lychee a podcast
again so we don't know when we're going
but the MA I mean it's an official
meeting of the minds and like I'm a
little nervous I'm a little nervous but
I'm excited and I'm excited to prove to
Jack that we like her yeah I'd be like
she just Saul has already made her mind
up about us all we do is change hearts
and minds look out of course and anytime
someone comes on our show when we like I
don't like them at first a la Leeanne
Locken and then she changed our minds
and our best friends they're like that's
what happens speaking of Lee Ann I have
so many thoughts about real house only
really sorry I think I might have to do
a one-woman patreon episode all right
just go in because I'm gonna lose them
all and I got so many pertinent thoughts
I've really been watching with an
analytical eye all of the housewives
okay
um anyways when it comes to Kate and
Meghan on the one hand I agree with you
she takes off her mask when she gets
home but I also do appreciate the fact
that when she is in the spotlight she is
very poised
of course she's an actress no but like
Princess Diana wasn't always that way
you know but her over there but it's
also been six months
right so Princess Diana in the first six
months was also like no darling thank
you darling and they drove her and you
know what it makes me think about cuz
I've been watching Real Housewives of
Dallas and you need to watch because the
evolution of Cameron Wescott yeah it's
very interesting to me because it's like
I never thought I would could just like
a housewife more than her and this
season it's not that I love her
hey so I'm just like seeing her and I
put it on my story and TPG agreed with
me made me feel very very seeing very
seen and that made me feel like you
would agree to it well not the to [ __ ]
and it's like she married into this
family and she's really taken it on and
she would be an amazing royal because
like she understands the duty and the
importance you know and she doesn't take
it lightly if anything she takes it too
heavily and makes it too serious but
it's just like you live in Highland Park
like you're not in Kensington Palace but
maybe she should be like she would be a
great royal of what was my thought yeah
and she's very regal with her posture
and her height and like she's really
getting more beautiful and stylish every
day I will catch up okay all that I need
to catch up on anything you can't catch
up on Dallas New Jersey oh I know see
what should I catch up on first Alice
okay that I can do yeah because it's
really I still don't know who that
haven't recorded that's why I still
don't know how I feel about about
everything okay but I will reunion next
week you got to do fun yeah it looks
salacious Deandra
she said Ivan I've had it I've known a
secret about LeeAnn for years and I've
never shared it and then she's gonna
share it cuz her and LeeAnn haven't
spoken since right and LeeAnn was on our
show talking [ __ ] about DeAndre so it's
not good
Chuck Chuck okay next story just a fun
little story if you're living in Houston
an ATM in Houston accidentally spit out
a hundred dollar bills instead of ten
dollar ills customers will get to keep
the money
customers who accidentally received $100
bills instead of ten dollar bills at a
Houston ATM get to keep the cash Bank of
America says it was overnight Sunday
into Monday when deputies in North
Harris County saw a crowd gathered
around ATM customers told deputies the
machine was dispensing $100 bills by
mistake deputies blocked off the ATM and
cleared the crowd before notifying the
bank of the error Bank of America later
sent out the following statement to a
local news source quote this was an
incident in a single ATM in Houston
cause when a vendor in correctly loaded
$100 bills in place of $10 bills we have
resolved the matter customers will be
able to keep the additional money
dispensed well [ __ ] snitches snitched
on Sunday night and called the police oh
my god well losers I'm like salty that
this wasn't me no same but it's crazy
that this was cause well the most you
can take out is a thousand it's a
thousand dollars but it doesn't come in
ten so you have to like take out a
hundred at a time oh that's true it
seems like a full-time job and by the
way and what if they give you a ten
instead of a hundred did they tell you
what the total damage was I'm so curious
I'm so curious but it's crazy that this
was caused by human error you know right
because you think like but I had never
seen did you watch Breaking Bad now
there's an episode where like these like
druggies like need money and they steal
an ATM and in their house they spend
like days trying to like hammer it open
when you open it like the money comes
flying out there's so much money in ATMs
like we gotta steal some no that's like
the show
Chesapeake Jones not the person and
she's like she's really strong less her
superpower and when she wants money she
just goes to an ATM and opens it like
with her strength oh that's what I would
use my super power for right but she
never she only did that in her teens
like now she doesn't even use money she
wears the same clothes every day
how does she pay her rent though um
she's a private investigator because she
use her strength to find stuff and got
it from place to place and like okay
it's a really good show I was gonna say
sounds like a terrible show no it's
really good it's really we it's twisted
by the way like this [ __ ] never happens
to me like I would be in the news story
where it's like ATM accidentally falls
on girl you know like that's me no mine
would be ATM accidentally dispenses $10
bills instead of yeah no no I would get
like I would just never be one of these
people in Houston totally screwed okay
so our fifth and final story today was
not chosen before the show started
because truly nothing happened
and so instead I'm gonna fall back on
yeah what Zoey no please I see what's on
your iPad I really don't to talk about
these people you don't want to talk
about Nick and Priyanka what about the
fact that Megan and Harry are not going
into kanakas wedding even though
Priyanka is Megan's best friend shocking
Megan Marco doing something selfish I'm
kidding I don't know why I'm like still
to god Megan Markel today okay you know
what I'm gonna give you something juicy
okay then let's go to Deer toasters cool
Mac Miller's secret Instagram account
was discovered after his death that is
interesting it's been nearly three
months since Mac Miller's tragic death
on Thursday fans uncovered a new aspect
of the late Roberts private life he had
a secret Instagram account by posting to
the account at Cloudy with a Chance of
Awesome 69 and posing as a man named
Lars the recording artist was able to
fly under the radar in July 2017
Miller's alter-ego revealed he had
garnered 50 followers a drastic
difference from the millions of
followers he had obtained in his
official account so what kind of content
did the star post most of the videos and
images centered on the topic of vaping
oh I did skip a story today sorry we'll
get to that next because vaping reminded
me this wasn't the first time Miller
hadn't used an alias during his lifetime
over the course of his career he also
released music under the pseudonyms
delusional Thomas Larry fisherman and
Larry love Stein this also wasn't the
only flashback fans received this week
Spotify also recently released two
tracks Miller had recorded before he
died very crazy very crazy a lot of
celebrities have big Instagram accounts
I was looking at someone's the other day
that someone I know follows it's a
private instrument it's like someone
really famous and I feel like if I said
I'm gonna get them in trouble but it
only has like 17 followers and the
person has been like am ia for a while
but they've been posting on that big
Instagram account and it was wildly
interesting very interesting and that
was only the fourth story I'm sorry the
fifth story speaking of vaping Altria
which is a major cigarette holding
company they owned Marlboro Marlboro
Marlboro Marv blow and Parliament is in
talks to take a significant minorities
jool okay I've been waiting for someone
to bite you all because it's crazy it's
gonna be perhaps not buying it but
they're investing in it so they believe
in the power of a thing more so like
right next generation of cigarettes Wow
I mean a Joule I don't know what the
valuation of Joule is cuz it's not a
public company but like it must be like
valued at 16 billion dollars in funding
from this summer I was gonna say
multi-billion dollar company one because
everyone does it - they're getting
people smoking who like when you think
smoking you think like old men women are
gr jeweling kids are drilling it's like
terrible but like teens are drooling
I like I've just been waiting for like
the financial part of Jul to come to
fruition because I find it so
interesting and like literally five
years ago I got a box from jail and
throw it away and like I just I didn't
know what a goldmine it was like I could
have a gone steak or something I'm like
I'm really intent about oh damn it was
like just a small detail startup I just
think this is a really interesting turn
of events like and it's also funny
because like jewel is I don't know if
they're trying to be like the
anti-smoking or to get people to stop
smoking cigarettes but it is one way
some people wane off of cigarettes and
it's like now cigarettes
there are deceptive funding we were
moving in the right direction but I
don't know I'm not here for like
everyone is like acts like this
cigarette companies are evil and it's
like these MTV commercials I can't stand
like know the truth and it's like nobody
is like being force-fed cigarettes like
do I think smoking cigarettes is
disgusting yes am I upset that someone
makes a personal choice to go buy them
no like that's your own deal some people
could say like me eating a pop-tart
yesterday is like the same thing you
know right personal choice it's pretty
well I still don't care those truth
commercials are coming for ecigs - I
know those commercials are like backed
by some PACs and like I don't know
they're so corrupt there's something so
eerie about them it's like like why do
you hard-on for Marlboro know why you
have a hard-on and also coming from like
a network MTV that's like it's not like
they're the cleanest network knowing
yeah like they're the pillar of
excellency right it's not like PBS was
right showing truth commercials I would
take it a little more serious no those
quarter-latino sense like it's just a
24-hour like promotion for drinking sex
and smoking pot I don't know it's like
why is that where we draw the line we
know it's a true life I'm addicted to
her
right don't smoke cigarettes it's just
so weird
and by the way I don't get me wrong I
think cigarettes are disgusting but I'm
just not here for like I don't know it's
like it's a business and it's like
people want to buy it like it's not like
anyone's being forced to buy cigarettes
they like it right if I'm okay
life's short smoke a cigarette now I'm
totally gonna live short maybe you do
all we how crazy think Matt is jewel is
like you don't know the effects that
it's gonna have on right because it's a
new thing and like in 50 years be like
wow I came loose to smoke Jules but when
Heather McMahon was here she was saying
that now with vaping it's a new thing
that's gonna be a problem called popcorn
lung have you heard of this yep you've
heard of popcorn low because from all
the like bubbles in your lungs so just
can't win we are gonna move on to deer
toasters which is a segment we do we
haven't done it in a while it is ice
Eggman so if you want some advice
you know us at Deer toasters at
gmail.com we take any advice but we
really look for the more interesting
types of advice a la you know DNA
speculation things like that we do a lot
of wedding you know co-worker drama but
that's kind of boring we've gotten some
really interesting ones and today's no
exception sometimes like I don't know
how to solve them and then I feel bad so
I kind of like the boring ones okay so
this one is I'm gonna start with the
least the most boring and then work our
way out I just got so hungry okay well
about 40 minutes ago I realize I'm not
wearing deodorant so oh this is caught
what is OTP oh one true pair right it's
like a what is it about a relationship
okay sure once your pair [ __ ] dilemma
oh I'm sorry
OTP over-the-pants hand job oh thank you
it also means once you pair let's look
at urban dictionary because I feel like
old and stupid yeah like a grandma using
the microwave okay wait
OTP Irina cherry is the most disgusting
place on the internet you had to stay
with him yes sorry okay one true pairing
that's the first thing that comes up is
anything else come up um oh it's
definitely over the one true pairing
no in this situation it's over at pants
we all know an OTP HJ that's what it's
the OTP HJ okay dear Claudia and Jackie
oh my husband reconnected with an old
childhood friend that recently moved to
our town let's call him Adam
I was really happy that Adam of my
husband would get to hang out again and
we planned a double date to get together
that night was disastrous oh my god the
girl accidentally um she put his real
aim because she like whose name Adams
real name cuz like I was like who's Adam
and his girlfriend were really into the
PDA to the point that I could feel other
people staring while we were at dinner
they went on a double date yes I'm with
Adam and his girlfriend she also made a
few flirty comments to my husband which
I brushed off until the night got even
weirder
and she started stroking Adams crotch
area it basically turned into an
over-the-pants hand job and it may have
been the longest five minutes of my life
it was clear that I could never be
friends with Adams girlfriend and double
dates worked definitely out of the
picture however any time my husband and
Adam get together to watch football grab
dinner play golf she shows up you know
he surprises my husband but he doesn't
think it's appropriate to say anything
so she's showing up without the girl
being there he's tried giving hints but
he was suggesting a guys night but it's
not working
help I don't want my husband to stop
hanging out with Adam but this really
bothers me am I crazy what do I do
that would bother me and it's like
you're stuck that was either me to cuz
like I fix this like art no more double
dates so when the boys hang out that
girls come in right and then it's like
she's being flirty with your husband so
you have to be there you gotta protect
yo man yo it's a little bit of a
lose-lose but I think you just have to
have your husband put his foot down with
Adam be like guy time period and I don't
think that's so crazy and if Adam like
thinks that that's weird then he's he's
weird yeah like no like every I Ben
loves me so much but like he needs to
get away from me sometimes and like
that's normal right and it's like if
zach if I was always like tagging onto
like Zach's guys my thing and then he
said to me like hey it's just guys maybe
like okay no and I would I was so weird
tag me on to a night where there was no
other girls right but and if I was if I
didn't even feel weird and then I was
told like not to like I wouldn't take
offense that of course this girl is
clearly weird um and it sounds like it's
gonna work out it was like a legit dude
and he'll get you know he'll move on
from the over-the-pants hand jobs and
like see her for who she really is
I mean I would die like I would never
like touch a penis in public no that's
I'm never touching penis in private
either so uncomfortable but anyways just
have your husband for this but downing
you know what you guys seem like a cool
couple like worst case scenario him and
Adam don't
he'll make other friends okay that was
just like to get us started because this
one is wild it's titled the chubby
chasing cheater I love a good
alliteration
I got a huge pit even writing the
subject line okay let me jump right in
this girl's very dramatic the other week
my boyfriend of four years turned his
phone to me to show me a snapchat his
friend had sent him of a dog the snap
cleared and I noticed several girls
names on his recent list I asked him
about it and he brushed it off saying
they were friends from high school that
send masse snaps out all the time I went
full Nancy Drew I went full Nancy Drew
in his phone anyways and found lots of
sexting received and sent pictures
included between him and said girls I've
never heard of any of them we went to
high school in the same small town so I
sent one of them a message letting her
know I was his girlfriend and what the
[ __ ] was up with these messages and what
the extent of the relationship was she
said no physical contact had been had
and that they just had messages back and
forth and she said she found his profile
on this website and sent me a link I
clicked on it and I was horrified it was
a website that is basically Facebook but
for fetishes literally just a community
of people with weird-ass sexual
interests like I thought I was kinky
until I saw some of this [ __ ] on there
and I realized I'm Way more vanilla than
I thought I did a little digging and
apparently my boyfriend is into feet ism
how do you spell that f ee D is M
basically he gets off on weight gain and
gorging his partner with food and he is
into super large women his profile said
he attended several feet ism / orgy
events in the area - I confronted him
about it and devastated and he brushed
it off and said he had never met any
other women he talks to online and that
he had never attended any of the events
either and that the whole thing is just
something he logs on to when he's bored
and is as harmless as watching porn what
the [ __ ] do I do do I break up with him
or do I brush it off
- and just chalk it up to a weird
fantasy thing he has should I feel crazy
because I think talking to local
strangers and exchanging photos and
pictures and texts is so much worse than
watching porn stars that you'll never
mean I feel cheated on and have a pit
larger than all the women
[Laughter]
and subsequently feel unattractive in
his eyes now that I'm not as large as
the women he's apparently in to help
gonna go ironically eat my feelings now
because [ __ ] I'm not well and then she
sent a follow-up message she was like
just for reference I am the same height
and weight as Ashley Graham that's what
she said cheeses and some of the women
he's talking to is like four times the
size that's what she just wanted
reference that's it's good to understand
to me is a major problem because you
know what it is it's like whatever your
interests are like him being into but
that's not the problem the problem is
the secrecy like the worst of all lying
straight to your face it's only a serial
killer lies like that right and I'm not
gonna be jack anyone's yeah I'm not
gonna put down fetishes or websites or
kinky [ __ ] but there's a different like
if he was just watching porn of really
big women like that's his fetish but
that's that's the same as watching porn
but this is driving for like human
contact is weird right and especially
like the locals aspect like you could
see these people at the grocery store
you're watching porn and then you get in
contact with that point starting or
sending pictures like that's wrong
that's cheating
that's cheating and this is said because
they've been together for four years and
I have to tell you girl like you have
got to break up with this yeah really
really and it's not because he is weird
fetishes because no one's fetishes are
weird like it's what they like but he's
a liar and a cheater and everybody
doesn't see anything wrong with him he's
trying to make you think that it's
normal right right like bringing you
into the cult who start gorging new
right and then it's like if that's what
your husband your boyfriend's really
into and you're not that like I would
feel like that's what she said she's
like I feel unattractive because he's
looking for a specific type of person
that I don't look like right that would
that would hurt me that would hurt me
too and I wouldn't be able to get be
like his bed was into skinny girls you
know he's not don't worry um I gotta go
I wouldn't be able to get past it and he
would have to he would have to go guts
and ago he lied he lied to you about the
snapchat stuff you're such a [ __ ]
liar Camille so how can you trust him
and without trust you don't have a
relationship because he could have told
you in that instance my quarter this is
what I'm into I'm sorry I was I was
sneaking around because I'm embarrassed
but now that you know about it like
let's fall into this together someone
said I have a fetus in relationship with
myself i gorge myself all the time all
the time every day and I'm not
embarrassed cuz I'm open with myself
okay final one and by the way if you
guys have
some weird scenarios you've on our take
on dear toasters at gmail.com and also
then I guess another option would have
been for her to like indulge in his
radish and to be fetus fed become a
fetish but don't let someone change like
I know Joe make yourself on the whole
thing just to satisfy someone else right
if someone goes either way if I wasn't
someone that wanted me to lose 20 pounds
I wouldn't do that if I was with someone
that wanted me to give I was saying that
like no one should change you if you
like the way you are agreed okay this is
the final one called a future felon in
the family dear toasters first of all I
want to say that my sister and I love
you guys and we are huge fans of all
things toast we trust no one but you two
in the toaster community to help us
navigate through this pit that comes
around at every holiday sorry in advance
for the long story but every detail is
important we come from a big family we
are really close with all of our cousins
we love our cousin we'll call her Ashley
but we are not as close with her as we
are the rest of our cousins Ashley's 33
and has been dating this guy in his mid
for days calling him John they've been
dating for four years Ashley and John
for years seems to be one thing yes go
awry start to I thankfully me men have
been over the four-year bump after
they'd been dating about a year Ashley
casually mentioned to our other cousin
we'll call her Sarah something about his
pet her boyfriend's past Sarah of course
googled him immediately and found
multiple articles about the time he
served in prison for over ten years
turns out he and some friends helped
were seeing he and some friends held at
gunpoint during a bank robbing spree and
stole over a million dollars before
getting caught and arrested once Sarah
the other cousin realizes it wasn't long
before the rest of our cousins aunts and
uncles knew but the only people two
people we aren't sure that know are her
parents our question if is how do we
somehow tell our parents and risk being
the ones to break the news to them or do
we not say anything and just hope for
the best
we can't imagine our entire family
knowing something and not telling us so
we were in her parent cheese I'm sure we
would want to know it's important to
note that when John isn't around is
around he doesn't talk to any of us it
doesn't participate in any family games
and just sits in the corner not
interacting with anyone oh so he's
Jackie not playing any games even our
dad who gives everyone the benefit of
the doubt has personally hit it a lot so
many games in Utah you did you tried you
tried even harder to I beat you at
Trivial Pursuit even our dad I beat you
the first time then even our dad who
gives everyone the benefit of the doubt
has personally hidden and locked up our
wallets and jewelry when John comes over
because no one trusts him he
major crimes oh they're doing that
knowing he robbed him yes but the girl's
parents don't know right they've been
dating long enough and it's at the point
where they feel like they will probably
get engaged any time now in the past
Ashley has had a really bad
relationships and was terrible was
engaged to another guy who was terrible
and ended up calling off the whole
wedding over text message we would hate
to see her heartbroken again if this
would all come out later and cause drama
and ruin the relationship we just don't
know what the right thing to do is I
mean we want this pit to go away so we
don't have to live with it at every
holiday or family gathering ps4 the
scenes only here's the link to the
article about the robbery okay I'm just
gonna read it like on my own okay so I
think that a hundred percent you should
tell her parents
straight worse and you don't even have
to worry about how you how you say it
you could even text them the link and be
like holy [ __ ] and I just found it
because you're doing it out of concern
not out of gossip right and they need to
know just because even if they don't
tell her or they something they just
need to know to lock their jewelry and
they're and they're right and like
imagine that get married have kids and
then like years later they found out
that he's a robber and then you knew
about it but I have a hard time
believing that they don't know right so
uh well I actually have a hard time
leading that she doesn't know you don't
Google the person that you're with all
right of course so you should definitely
tell the parents because they probably
don't know cuz like they don't think to
Google people um and they should just
know that so that they can you know
safeguard their home and then leave it
up to them if they want to tell her but
I I actually feel like she might know
and that it's not a deal breaker for her
because if you go from being with
someone who treats you terribly and
calls off your way over text message
like someone who robbed a bank for a
million dollars like at least he was
aiming high I don't know like the whole
honesty robbing a bank like is an epic
of a deal to me cuz it's like it's a
victimless crime to start acting right
the gunpoint and like literally scaring
all the patrons in the bank like that's
where you lost me like I would rob a
bank if I could get away with it like
[ __ ] Bank you know but the poor
people like itll old lady with her cane
you know like she said yeah the gunpoint
is is no bueno and it's also doing it to
ten different banks seems excessive in
like kind of breeding ten different bank
yeah that was just one like no sugar and
spice style mm-hmm okay so it's not a
sugar and spice situation I know so I'm
afraid you're gonna have to tell and
like this girl can get married to this
guy yeah oh so it's one thing to like
date someone who got arrested for like
smoking pot like having a like marrying
someone who has like something on their
record or like has been to prison isn't
the worst thing in the war
Oh No but for robbing a bank at gunpoint
like where did he get the gun that's bad
agree but she also is kind of the weird
cousin so maybe like she knows she
doesn't care but the parents should know
that's who you should worry about town
yeah let them take it from there um and
I have a feeling she knows so don't I
have you a chance to know like I'm sorry
some people use a should be together if
she doesn't know they should not and
also it's like if she doesn't know what
like this is gonna sound something like
she deserves everything she's gonna get
like how do you not know that and how do
you not Google your husband right so
silly and he should have just gone to
the ATM in Houston giving out hundred
thank you for bringing it full circle
rocky that's what the morning toast is
all about you're so welcome
I'm a learning woman okay Skillshare
really paying off oh my god by the way
I've been taking online online
Skillshare classes because we talked we
talked about it on the toast like two
weeks ago and it really piqued my
interest and I set up an account and
like it's really it's it's I don't know
if it's helping because as you guys know
I have like a bad brain and I don't know
what it's from maybe from watching a lot
of TV as a child or I don't know I don't
know what it's from but it's there and
I've decided to start taking online
classes in all different a variety of
fields there's like a million that you
could take on Skillshare
there's over 20,000 classes in business
design technology and more I need to
take some more business classes for the
chose but I'm taking like some
technology ones like I just need my
brain till I get back to where it was in
like the 10th grade and I'm not there
yet but skill shows really helping that
is a great idea I feel like I have the
opposite issue I have a good brain but I
need to learn more skills such as like
Photoshop and video editing yeah because
we need to learn video editing nobody
even yesterday that amanda Bynes thing
that I made you do like I should be able
to do that and Skillshare will teach me
what I need to know and if any of you
are interested you can join the millions
of students already learning on
Skillshare too very today with a special
offer just for our listeners go to
Skillshare comm slash toast and get two
months of Skillshare for just 99 cents
that's really crazy because education is
so expensive and this is skills but 99
cents and these are real skills that you
can share so it's like 99 cents you can
get fries from McDonald's or become a
learning individual or just get two
dollars and get both or two
months of classes that's right
Skillshare is offering morning toast
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 20,000 classes for just 99 cents
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
toast go start your two months now at
skill shared calm sighs totes and
Melissa Fuentes who is a toaster said
Skillshare is really good I owe a lot to
it
that's me because a lot of people don't
have time or the resources to like learn
these things if I wanted to like learn
Photoshop I wouldn't even know where to
go right now I do skills hair comm /host
get two months that's amazing so what is
our plans for the rest of the week let's
give a little overview of the net coming
months will do so tomorrow show Claudia
and I we have a guest singing el Carolyn
she's a youtuber and toaster and she has
really premium content I'm excited to
talk to her
and then I'm hopping on a plane from LAX
with a dream and my cardigan I'm going
to Alabama show sold out I [ __ ] just
love the toasters like always showing up
for me when I really need them like my
team was like you really gonna have to
cancel the show in Hoover I'm like
really watch this [ __ ] look what we did
and then I've two more shows after that
through the rest of the year in Miami
one of them sold out and I added a
second show because everyone was yelling
at me so now you have to buy it cuz I
did it cuz for you check it's about
merch available at chop girl with no job
com
then on Sunday presale tickets for kam
toast oh my god it's Sunday already
Monday December just really crept up on
us that's debt wow I'm so excited for
chem chose to round to like I feel like
we did cam to us around one it was
unbelievable we learned a lot we're
throwing it all back breaking work into
camp chose to I'm so excited and I need
to start worrying my deluxe bedding
because major I'm gonna have the most
comfortable that at Camp tosylate me too
I went to camp what's wrong on it wasn't
a priority for me and I really suffered
yeah I've never been so broken in my
life me too
anyways pre-sale goes on sale noon
Eastern Time on Sunday December 2nd
pre-sale is for patron members and camp
toast oh geez
attendees then print tickets go on sale
to everyone on Monday December 3rd at
noon Eastern Time
or whenever the show ends so if you're
watching live you will see us go live
with the tickets and then from there we
can just get really excited about camp I
know I'm really excited about chem do
you smell fire I do someone probably
burn are they cooking something that's
what happens when we go over an hour
Roberto's yeah
like 1137 everyone's like I get the [ __ ]
out of here ladies know what's good
I'm so hungry like I can't get over and
we need to eat something we did what are
you gonna what do you still go to the
doctor after this and I'm getting
weighed so I'm gonna eat afterwards Oh
scary stuff scary [ __ ] stuff bro I
haven't weighed myself since you time
and then do it on Saturday I made myself
this morning again and you same as
yesterday wow it's real yeah I just had
to make sure that I didn't that's that
doesn't make sense I know I'm like
really nervous it's like just wait I
know but that's not it's cuz I haven't
digested it yet it's like soul mate
that's not how it goes it's not know if
it's the opposite so like but that
justifies math I'm a simple math I know
I really think the buildings on fire
okay that would be a good reason to end
the show thank you all so much for
watching we love and adore you and the O
everything in our lives to you and you
know it
this is the morning toast the Millennial
morning show we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time we're
amazing we're also available as a
podcast we live stream on YouTube you
know what I'm giving you an assignment
recruit a toaster this week you guys are
the best like you we don't even need to
hire a publicist cuz you guys do it for
us like bring in a toaster forget
toaster to a show send them an episode
send the Instagram I'd like to send a
new person in episode what would you say
I don't know honestly
today's was great yeah I don't know
yesterday I didn't feel like I was on my
game I thought yesterday I didn't feel
like I was on my game but then in
reflecting on the episode I was like
damn that was a funny episode openly I
didn't like myself at all yesterday I
was like doubting myself a lot last
night I'm sorry but so I really feel
like I made up for it today and I wanted
to just clarify two things about cam
ptosis there's a lot of questions it's
Memorial Day weekend 2019 Friday to
Monday check-in is Friday afternoon
check out is Monday morning all the
information will be on the on that
bright tickets are costing six hundred
and fifty dollars so that is something
that you should know so you can empty
your piggy bank and come to camp yeah
included in that is three nights food
three meals a day snacks but premium
apps like pasta bar salad bar
omelet armlets station everything open
up your guard and all the once all the
fun you can have all the female
empowerment you can have all the friends
friends you can have corn all corn you
can all the entertainment you can have
camp because the toast goes live there
um you can come to campus and I cannot
bring the wallet I mean I wouldn't
recommend it
like because when you're at when you
leave camp you'll need why nobody might
be selling merch and also you get merged
with your ticket but also we're gonna
make extra merch and sell there if you
want it so maybe do bring your wallet oh
yeah that's it that's a good call um but
you do get free merch
included in your ticket so it really it
pays for itself and where else are you
gonna go for Memorial Day weekend for
$650 so sure that is so tomato going to
a three-day weekend on a holiday weekend
all-inclusive resort mm-hmm and like no
like resort fees that they spray for
$650 no because having if I were to go
anywhere for Memorial to begin would be
the Hamptons and like if you're doing a
house or if you're doing a the hotel
yeah it took a thousand dollars a night
mm-hmm
so three nights three thousand dollars
I'm you're gonna make memories in fronts
at last I'm like Lauren Yuki me 11 miss
you and you're gonna go on a zip line
and like do things that you never
thought that you would that you never
thought that you would do or if you've
done it never thought that you would do
again in life because when else are you
gonna go to camp exactly like waters not
water skiing but water tube tubing oh my
god that was the most fun I've ever try
and swing rock climbing Odyssey which we
didn't get to do last time because was
raining but this time the weather should
be knock on mother nature shown up a lot
better and it's crazy even though was
raining the whole time last time and it
couldn't have been worse weather like if
we tried nobody cared we served it like
it didn't affect us because we were all
so happy to be together and it was like
we were just wet and happy that's three
to be ladies love you so much we will
see you tomorrow
you